I'm really excited about giving advice
because I've lived a life and a lot of
people have said I've lived a Champion's
life right people have said you live in
Champions that's what I hear that um
like Brian Kelly lives in Champions
League yeah okay
um I want you to think people have said
that I want you to dress differently no
so I can't I've actually tried to I know
me too no no I've tried to dress
differently but you look like the guy
who didn't make it in NASCAR but you
know what is that fair but here's what I
don't know if that's fair well you know
it's like it's like it's like he would
have done it he would he would have had
it but he got all caught up you know nah
dude listen no you look like the guy he
got caught up that's the problem I tried
it I heard he was amazing
yeah he had all the talent he would have
been a superstar but he got caught up
with driving just out of [__] you know
to drugs and stuff yeah all that dude
you look like you did all the drugs and
all the booze you went through your face
and and now you're out of it but it's
too like it's too late you never drank
no no I never drank dude you know that
yeah you suffer probably from the guy I
don't you know what I've done mustard
turkey and no sun you know what dude
what I don't suffer
period right
we can agree okay
look yeah I am looking and you know what
I see what
careful okay because you see somebody
who's squared away and put together I
tell you what you see and I'm gonna say
this I'm glad we're doing this if you
and I are walking down the street
separately
they're mugging the [__] out of you
right no because you don't look like
you're squared away you look like a
whole bunch of different moving Parts
everything about you is in shambles it's
unorganized that guy could have made it
in NASCAR but he didn't I'm not going to
say that nobody's saying I look like I
could have made it in NASCAR but I did
it might also say he's been on a boat
for too long dude that's not true why
you look like you've been on a boat like
I'm disheveled I'm organized my body's
unorganized yeah you look like you've
been on a boat I'm not saying you're a
Castaway although you could be I'm
saying you just been on a boat for too
long tearing up in the dark you never
even got off the [__] off the boat
you stayed in the slip and you drank
until you guys got to the next [__]
slip what's a slip
it's just it's where you put your boat
okay you pay a slip fee dock like a
docking it you're the [__] steer that
dude I don't I I the point is this
before you talk about my [__]
appearance if you're walking down the
street it's fine if you're walking down
the street yeah I'm not getting
Predators Predator see like the wounded
animal okay you gotta you gotta you got
a limp or something's going on with your
[__] because your legs are not
everything I don't have a limp dude and
my legs are [__] fine size okay but
they're skinny a little bit but yes but
there's this right there's this you see
me there's no wasted space right there
are no errant Parts Brian you see
someone who's squared away You're
squared away yeah okay and he's gonna
give you the what for it and meet you
halfway if there's a problem don't step
to them because he's got eyes everywhere
and I'm [__] cat quick and I'll tell
you something else what I'm on the balls
of my feet that doesn't matter dude
listen until it comes down no yours
comes down mini your mini there I said
it your mini I've always wanted to tell
you that no I'm no you're a mini your
mini your head's mini your shoulders are
mini
dude you're and there's no you are you
are not 170. yes I am no you're not and
and you're five what nine I'm fine for
real bro be real you're 911 I'm in
flip-flops right now get a tape do we
have a tape measure no I mean we don't
have a [__] tape and I'm taller than
five eleven you're not five eleven and
yes I am too you got one he's got one
come over he's got one [__] he's
got one we measure the height yeah
yeah dude I'm look at that look at how
square away I am look at my shoulders
three inches
I'm in flip-flops I'm in my toe holds
all right what's it say okay oh it says
511. there we go look how I look at 511.
this one's right here for me no it's not
no it's not no you are taller oh [__] oh
[__] I'm six I'm almost six three
okay hey dude hey you got shoes on
e-mini
[Music]